y
no no no
[Música]
con su construcción valles enteros
fueron sumergidos y más de un millón de
personas tuvieron que abandonar sus
hogares para dar paso a una de las
estructuras más grandes costosas
poderosas y polémicas del mundo hace una
década china terminó la presa de las
tres gargantas poseedora de cifras
asombrosas 185 metros de altura más de 2
kilómetros de longitud y un costo
superior a los 27 mil millones de
dólares cada año su producción
energética equivale a la de 15 reactores
nucleares desde 2014 ha generado la
mayor cantidad de energía hidroeléctrica
del mundo pero también ha provocado
diversos desastres ambientales y humanos
su construcción no sólo provocó
desplazamientos de la población y
sumergió aldeas sitios históricos y
valles enteros sino que también alteró
profundamente la biodiversidad algunas
especies animales han desaparecido era
necesaria la emblemática y gigantesca
construcción nuestros reporteros
visitaron la región
[Música]
para celebrar su unión estos recién
casados han elegido una gran ceremonia
una boda en masa es una tradición en
china
[Música]
28 parejas se unen al mismo tiempo y no
en cualquier lugar al pie de la presa de
las tres gargantas inaugurada hace
apenas diez años es un símbolo para
estos jóvenes esposos procedentes de
toda china
otros
si yo
la obra hidráulica también es halagada
por su espíritu patriótico porque está
presa china como las superlativos es la
presa más grande más potente y más cara
que se haya construido hasta ahora
porque nada
esta pareja vino a sellar su amor con la
gran historia china
estoy muy emocionado
y esta ceremonia de boda está llena de
significado y es diferente a otras
ceremonias
normalmente son solo amigos y familiares
aquí es como casarse delante de todo el
pueblo
y
es delante de la presa y de este gran
río que venimos a hacer nuestra promesa
de amor
este monstruo de concreto de 2
kilómetros de largo y 185 metros de alto
fue la mayor obra de construcción china
del siglo 20 10 años después de su
puesta en servicio la presa logró su
objetivo tomar el río yangtsé y aumentar
la producción de electricidad cada año
la energía hidroeléctrica producida por
la estructura equivale a la de 15
reactores nucleares algo nunca antes
visto hoy gracias a la presa la vida de
los habitantes de la región está
transformada ya no sufren ningún corte
de energía para los líderes de china
esta obra es una vitrina de la
renovación de la nación en una visita al
valle de las tres gargantas hace dos
años el presidente chino xi jinping
aclamado por los trabajadores de el
sitio elogió el éxito del proyecto
la presa de las tres gargantas es un
símbolo
sólo podríamos contar con nosotros
mismos para llevar a cabo este proyecto
estoy muy feliz de estar aquí y de poder
verlo
siento más confianza ahora como todos
ustedes ayudan a cada talla
pero esta presa desmedida también es
fuente de mucha controversia
con su construcción valles enteros
fueron sumergidos un total de 1.400.000
personas tuvieron que dejar su tierra
abandonar sus hogares para dar paso a la
obra
a 400 km de la presa en un valle aguas
arriba del río yangtsé este antiguo
campesino fue uno de los primeros en ser
expropiados prefiere permanecer en el
anonimato la presa es un tema delicado
incluso treinta años después del
lanzamiento del proyecto mi casa estaba
allí junto los bambúes y allí estaba mi
taller donde descascarada las espigas de
trigo y hacía harina
vivía aquí con su esposa y su padre una
casa familiar amenazada por la crecida
de las aguas
el nivel del agua comenzó a subir casi a
2 metros
estaba cerca de mi casa que quedó muy
cerca del agua
temía que la crecida del río inundará mi
casa así que me dijeron que me mudara
hoy más de 20 años después de su
expropiación es la primera vez que
vuelve a la escena conmovido y enojado
este lugar me pone muy triste fue una
buena idea construir la presa pero
hubiera sido mejor volver a alojar a los
expropiados
y hoy en día no tengo donde vivir
estoy en la miseria la vida no tiene
sentido ahora
después de su expropiación las
autoridades le ofrecieron trasladarse a
una provincia vecina a 800 kilómetros de
su casa
pero sin un hogar y sin una tierra para
seguir cultivando se negó a irse
hoy a los 64 años sin trabajo y sin
dinero se estableció en esta ciudad
cerca del río
alquila una pequeña habitación en un
sótano que comparte con una familia
esta es la entrada al apartamento aquí
está la cocina y ese es mi dormitorio
viviendas insalubres en las que las
condiciones de vida son difíciles pero
no tiene otra opción después de haberlo
expropiado las autoridades sólo le
ofrecieron tres mil euros de
indemnizaciones y una pensión
compensatoria de seis euros al mes
este es el documento que certifica que
soy un inmigrante de tres gargantas está
firmado por un oficial y esta es la
prueba de mi compensación
las autoridades destruyeron mi casa y
luego vendieron los ladrillos
pero no les importaba pensar a dónde
iría después
antes vivía en el campo tenía cultivos
podía trabajar la tierra tenía
suficiente para vivir hoy no tengo nada
ni cultivos ni dinero
en su pueblo no es el único que denuncia
a estas expropiaciones como el otros
habitantes fueron forzados a abandonar
su tierra y 20 años después su vida aún
continúa
hola a todos
toma una silla y siéntate hoy tienen una
cita para revisar sus reclamaciones
siguen pidiendo más compensación aceptan
testificar con el rostro descubierto
porque ellos son conocidos por las
autoridades por sus protestas para ellos
no hay nada que perder
aún quedan 150 euros por pagarnos nos
mudamos hace 20 años y sólo recibimos
2500 euros es eso suficiente para durar
20 años ellos también son antiguos
campesinos a los que las autoridades les
pidieron que abandonaran sus tierras
para una nueva vida lejos de su hogar
una situación que ellos se encuentran
inaceptable
a menudo nos reunimos para discutir los
problemas relacionados con nuestra
expropiación
nos quejamos ante el gobierno local pero
nadie nos escucha
no sabemos a quién pedirle ayuda
estamos a favor de la presa de las tres
gargantas es nuestro deber apoyar el
proyecto pero deberíamos recibir mejor
ayuda
entre estos campesinos nadie discute la
existencia misma de la presa a pesar del
método utilizado para expropiarlos todos
apoyan este gran proyecto del estado sin
embargo la presa de las tres gargantas
no sólo produjo desplazamientos de
poblaciones sino que también alteró
profundamente la biodiversidad del río
yangtsé
arriba del tanque chongqing 34 millones
de personas
con la presa el transporte fluvial se
fortaleció
la ciudad antes aislada se transformó en
un centro económico
pero hoy en día en las aguas del tercer
río más grande del mundo casi no quedan
peces las redes de los pescadores están
vacías sus barcos permanecen en el
muelle como naufragios
este era nuestro barco no solíamos usar
para viajes cortos
me sentaba aquí y nos íbamos
y es un antiguo pescador durante 25 años
navegó en las aguas del yangtsé pero el
año pasado no se le permitió trabajar en
noviembre del año pasado las autoridades
nos ordenaron dejar de pescar y destruir
nuestros barcos
nos dijeron que esta prohibición iba a
durar 10 años porque no quedan peces en
el río por eso no podemos pescar más
cuando vuelvan podremos volver a pescar
pero eso no será hasta dentro de 10 años
oficialmente son los pescadores y la
sobrepesca los responsables de la
desaparición de los peces pero chen yi y
sus colegas se niegan a asumir el rol
del culpable para ellos la razón es otra
tiene algo que ver con la presa debido a
que cortaron el río en dos los peces río
abajo no puede subir mientras que es en
los afluentes del río donde se
reproducen además del canal principal
así que tienen un impacto en las agua
del río arriba
antes de la presa podíamos pescar de 40
a 45 kilos de pescado cada día después
de la presa eran de 5 a 10 te das cuenta
de la diferencia
ahora en chongqing en las orillas del
río yangtsé solo se permite la pesca con
caña pero para estos aficionados es la
misma constatación nada muerde el
anzuelo
él
desde la construcción de la presa muchos
científicos estudiaron el proyecto
guiados por preguntas es indispensable
la estructura gigantesca cuáles son las
consecuencias para el medio ambiente
la presa causará más problemas de los
que resuelve en china solo un científico
accedió a responder a nuestras preguntas
pero su apartamento está bajo vigilancia
de las autoridades lo entrevistamos a
distancia
[Música]
división
cuando hablamos públicamente de la presa
es solo para evocar los aspectos
positivos
a cuestionar públicamente la presa está
prohibido
este geólogo especialista de empresas no
sólo está preocupado por la desaparición
de los peces también asegura que el agua
del yangtsé está más contaminada que
antes porque tiene dificultades para
regenerarse con la construcción de la
presa el agua fluye más lentamente por
lo que se regenera menos rápidamente
en el pasado cuando las aguas residuales
subían al río la alta velocidad del
flujo hacía que el agua se purificará
por sí misma
pero hoy en día el río fluye más
lentamente y la calidad del agua no es
tan buena como antes
más allá de las consecuencias ecológicas
a algunas personas les preocupan los
riesgos geológicos las fuertes lluvias
de este verano inundaron el centro de
china y llenaron el embalse de las tres
gargantas a un nivel nunca antes visto
desde su puesta en marcha
bajo el peso del agua algunos dicen que
la presa está en peligro de colapsar
el año pasado las fotos de satélite
publicados en internet y luego
censuradas sugerían una deformación en
la estructura las autoridades dicen que
no hay riesgo de ruptura pero a 9.000
kilómetros de distancia en alemania en
torno a un geólogo chino que tiene
prohibido publicar en china está
preocupado
[Música]
ferviente crítico de la presa y autor de
numerosos libros one whale wall se niega
a confiar en las palabras
tranquilizadoras del gobierno chino
el gobierno chino quiere ocultar algo al
principio dijo no hay deformaciones no
hay movimientos es una tontería todo
está en orden
y ahora dice sí
hay movimientos hay deformaciones pero
no sobrepasa el límite
el problema es que el gobierno no dice
cuál es el límite
finalista de las actitudes spray
si la estructura colapsara la gigantesca
cantidad de agua retenida por la presa
se tragaría parte de la ciudad de wuhan
a 400 km aguas abajo de las tres
gargantas
a pesar de las críticas el apetito de
las autoridades por la energía
hidroeléctrica no disminuye con 98 mil
presas china tiene más que cualquier
otro país del mundo y construcciones
como éstas continúan alterando la
biodiversidad y desplazando a las
poblaciones en todo el país
[Música]
hasta aquí boleto de vuelta a la presa
de las tres gargantas si desea ver
nuevamente este reportaje lo invitamos a
visitar france24 puntocom
[Música]